pride here in bolton northeast means
pride in the people who represent them
have the events in westminster in recent
days been a watershed moment for an area
that went blue for the first time in the
last general election boris johnson
captured this seat by under 400 votes
but are the mounting sleaze allegations
now weakening that bond they need to
concentrate on the running the country
never mind all the other things they
they
want to do to us all this squabbling i
believe to be honest best results they
need to work together for an mp is to
work with the people to make the
communities better
not to like
not to make it some sort of side hustle
gloomy mps gathered in parliament today
to work out what to do next after voting
to junk the system which polices them
last week then backtracking from time to
time
we talk about the house being at its
best
i regret to say that i don't think the
house has been its best in the way it's
handled the standard standard issues
over the last week
nasa under the prime minister but an
apology from his understudy i would like
first and foremost
to express my regret
and that to my ministerial colleagues
over the mistake made last week the
opposition on the attack no harm for
them in keeping this going rather than
repairing the damage that he's done
the prime minister is running scared
it's time for everyone in this house
whatever their party
to draw a line
and to send a message to the prime
minister enough is enough we will not
stand by why he trashes our democracy
even his own side turning on the absent
prime minister
if the team captain gets it wrong then i
think he should come and apologize to
the public and to this house
that's the right thing to do
uh in terms of demonstrating leadership
i'm very impressed
the prime minister was hundreds of miles
away visiting a hospital
will you apologize for the way you dealt
with the owen patterson and
parliamentary standards affair last week
so
what we've got to make sure is that we
we take all this very very seriously and
that we we get it right a big clear
promise you're not going to apologize
for the way you acted like that look i
think it's very important that we get
this right
and
we are going to make every effort to get
it right and we are going to hold mps to
account
is this a watershed moment for sleeves
well mps are watching their inboxes
nervously but what was potentially a
watershed was labor moving ahead of the
conservatives in the polls and boris
johnson getting lower satisfaction
ratings than at any point since he
became prime minister now that's
probably more to do with rising prices
higher taxes and recent disruption
but all these things coming up once for
the prime minister doesn't bode well for
the conservatives
mps discussed the need for more
discussions and agreed to take their
time with any reforms but how long will
the public give them